Lorsque D débuta l'école, il avait 6 ans :
mignon comme tout,
avec un sourire qui illuminait toute la pièce.
Mais après quelques mois d'école,
D est devenu coléreux,
et son sourire s’effaça.
D se mit à retourner des tables,
à lancer des bancs et des chaises,
à crier sur les enseignants,
à monter sur les appuis de fenêtres.
Il entrait et sortait des classes
et s’échappait même de l'école.
Parfois ses sautes d'humeurs
plaçaient l'école entière en état d'urgence
jusqu'à ce que D reprenne ses esprits,
ce qui pouvait prendre plus d'une heure.
Personne à l'école ne savait comment aider D.
Je le sais parce que j'étais la directrice de l'école.
Et j'ai vite compris avec mon équipe
que la situation était bien plus grave
que ce pour quoi nous avions été formés.
Chaque fois que D explosait,
je me disais :
« Qu'ai-je raté pendant ma formation ?
Que dois-je faire avec un enfant comme D ?
Et comment vais-je l'empêcher de perturber l'apprentissage
des autres élèves ? »
Et même après avoir fait tout ce qu'on nous avait appris,
comme discuter avec D,
lui retirer ses privilèges
et appeler ses parents,
la seule option qu'il nous restait était de le renvoyer,
et je savais que ça ne l'aiderait pas.
Cette situation n'est pas propre à D.
Des élèves partout dans le monde éprouvent des difficultés à l'école.
Et même si nous n'avons pas trouvé de solution miracle,
nous avons eu une idée très simple :
pour que des enfants comme D non seulement survivent à l'école
mais s'y épanouissent,
nous avons trouvé un moyen
non seulement de leur apprendre à lire et à écrire,
mais aussi de les aider à gérer leurs émotions.
Ce faisant,
nous avons élevé le niveau de notre école
parmi les moins performantes de l'État de l'Ohio
avec une moyenne de F
jusqu'à une moyenne de C, et ce, en quelques années seulement.
Cela semble logique, non ?
Évidemment que les enseignants devraient se préoccuper
du bien-être mental de leurs élèves.
Mais en pratique,
quand vous avez une classe de 30 élèves,
et que l'un d'eux vous lance son pupitre,
c'est beaucoup plus simple de l'exclure
que d'essayer de comprendre ce qu'il ressent.
Mais ce que nous avons appris sur D,
et sur les enfants comme lui,
c'est que de petits changements peuvent faire une grande différence,
et il est possible de s'y mettre dès maintenant.
Vous n'avez pas besoin d'augmentation de budget ou de grandes stratégies,
il faut juste revoir vos ressources et la façon dont vous les utiliser
de manière plus efficace.
En éducation, nous avons tendance à chercher les solutions ailleurs,
et nous dévouons peu de temps, d'argent et d'efforts
à développer ce que nous avons déjà.
C'est ainsi que de gros changements peuvent se produire rapidement.
Donc voici ce que j'ai appris sur D.
J'ai voulu creuser un peu plus et comprendre pourquoi il était si perturbé.
J'ai appris que son père avait quitté le domicile
et que sa mère travaillait énormément
pour subvenir aux besoins de la famille.
D a donc grandi sans adultes avec qui échanger,
et il avait la responsabilité de son petit frère après l'école.
Puis-je vous rappeler que D avait six ans ?
Je ne peux pas le blâmer d'avoir des difficultés à s'adapter à l'école.
Mais on devait trouver un moyen
pour l'aider à gérer ses émotions
tout en lui apprenant les bases de la lecture et des maths.
Trois choses nous ont particulièrement aidés.
Premièrement, il fallait comprendre ce qui l'angoissait le plus.
Comme pour la plupart des enfants,
l'arrivée à l'école peut être une transition difficile.
Ils passent d'un environnement familial décontracté
à un environnement scolaire plus structuré.
Nous lui avons donc créé un espace de relaxation
dans notre salle de repos,
équipée de chaises à bascule, de coussins et de livres.
D était autorisé à s'y rendre le matin,
isolé des autres enfants,
pour lui permettre de faire la transition
vers une atmosphère studieuse
à son aise.
En apprenant à connaître D,
nous avons découvert de nouvelles stratégies pour l'aider à s’apaiser.
Par exemple, D adorait aider les autres élèves,
donc nous l'avons nommé assistant en maternelle.
Il se rendait dans les classes
et apprenait aux enfants à écrire l'alphabet.
Il a même été capable d'aider ceux
avec lesquels le professeur avait des difficultés.
Et croyez-le ou non,
D a réussi à apaiser certains d'entre eux,
nous démontrant que les interactions entre enfants
sont bien plus influentes que celles avec les adultes.
Nous avons utilisé l'humour et la musique avec lui.
Oui, ça peut paraître fou
que la directrice et les professeurs plaisantent avec les enfants.
Vous pouvez imaginer l'étonnement de D
lorsque la directrice se mettait à faire des blagues ou à chanter,
ce qui provoquait presque toujours un éclat de rire
et nous permettait de raccourcir ses crises
tout en suscitant le contact.
Vous vous dites sûrement :
« Il est difficile en pratique de fournir
un traitement de faveur à chaque élève. »
Mais nous y sommes arrivés.
Parce qu'une fois les stratégies qui fonctionnaient avec D identifiées,
nos enseignants ont pu les appliquer aux autres élèves.
Au lieu de simplement réagir face aux problèmes comportementaux,
nous les résolvions de façon proactive.
Les professeurs ont ainsi pris du temps durant les leçons
pour apprendre aux enfants à décrypter leurs émotions
et à les gérer de façon appropriée et saine,
comme par exemple compter jusqu'à 10,
utiliser un hand spinner
ou aller se promener.
Nous avons instauré des pauses durant la journée,
permettant aux enfants de chanter,
de pratiquer le yoga,
et de participer à des activités sportives.
Pour ceux ayant des difficultés à rester assis durant de longues périodes,
nous avons investi dans des assises dynamiques,
comme des fauteuils à bascule, des vélos stationnaires
et des machines elliptiques au sol,
pour que les enfants puissent pédaler sous leurs bureaux.
Les enfants étaient désormais plus motivés à rester dans la classe,
plus concentrés et prêts à apprendre.
Avoir moins d'enfants turbulents
permet à tous de progresser.
Et le mieux dans tout ceci :
ça ne nous a pas ruinés.
Nous avons simplement repensé ce que nous avions.
Par exemple, chaque école est approvisionnée en fournitures.
Les fournitures peuvent être des livres,
des tableaux,
des assises dynamiques,
des hand spinners,
ou même de la peinture d'une couleur apaisante pour les murs de l'école
pour permettre aux élèves de s'épanouir.
Nous continuons d'investir dans des fournitures scolaires,
bien sûr,
mais nous investissons aussi sur le plan social.
Et les résultats parlent d'eux-mêmes.
Avoir pris le bien-être émotionnel de nos élèves au sérieux
et les avoir aidés à gérer leurs émotions
a entraîné une amélioration des résultats en lecture et en maths
bien au-delà des progrès espérés
et dépassant ceux des écoles avec une population similaire.
La seconde chose qui a permis d'aider ces élèves
fut le partage de compétences.
En tant qu'école publique ayant peu de subventions,
nous n'avions pas de personnels spécialisés
pour aider les élèves avec des difficultés familiales
et nous n'étions pas formés ou équipés pour nous en occuper.
Nous avons donc fait appel à des associations,
à des organismes communautaires,
et même à l'université d’État de l'Ohio.
Ce partenariat avec l'université
nous mit en lien avec des universitaires
étudiant l'éducation
ainsi que la psychologie et l'assistance sociale en milieu scolaire.
Ces étudiants ont collaboré avec les professeurs
pour accompagner les élèves dans le besoin.
Tout le monde en a bénéficié :
les enseignants ont profité de l'innovation universitaire,
et les étudiants ont pu travailler sur le terrain
dans les salles de classe.
Le Nationwide Children's Hospital avec qui nous collaborons
a construit une clinique au sein de notre école
pour offrir un suivi sanitaire et mental à nos élèves.
Ce fut un incroyable atout pour les enfants.
Le taux d'absentéisme diminua,
et les enfants avaient accès à un service d'aide
durant la journée.
Le plus grand changement ne s'opéra pas sur D ou sur les autres enfants.
Il concerna les adultes.
Les professeurs excellent dans l'éducation,
mais avec des éléments perturbateurs,
ils peuvent se sentir dépassés.
En prenant le développement émotionnel de nos élèves au sérieux,
nous avons cessé d'exclure
-- tu déranges, sors --
et avons privilégié la confiance et le respect.
Ça n'a pas été facile,
mais nous y tenions.
C'était un bond en avant,
et j'admire les professeurs qui ont sauté le pas avec moi.
Dans le cadre de notre projet de développement professionnel,
nous nous sommes intéressés aux études du Dr Bruce Perry
sur les effets qu'ont les expériences vécues durant l'enfance
sur le cerveau en développement des enfants.
Nous avons réalisé que l'enfance de certains de nos enfants -
par exemple,
des parents absents,
un quotidien chaotique,
la pauvreté ou la maladie -
a causé de véritables traumatismes à leurs cerveaux.
Oui, des traumatismes.
Je sais que c'est un mot fort,
mais cela nous a aidés à reconsidérer et à comprendre les comportements.
Ces situations familiales pénibles
étaient un frein à l'apprentissage
et nous devions le desserrer.
Les enseignants ont donc aménagé leurs cours,
les rendant plus courts et plus ciblés,
permettant aux enfants de participer.
Ils planifiaient des pauses pour se défouler
où les enfants pouvaient sauter
et danser en classe pendant deux minutes.
Nous savons que
les pauses permettent aux étudiants d'emmagasiner les informations.
Je me permets d'ajouter que le « Cha-Cha Slide »
est la chanson parfaite pour se défouler.
(Rires)
Les professeurs disaient :
« Qu'est-ce qu'il t'est arrivé ? »
et non « Qu'est-ce qui ne va pas chez toi ? »
ou « Comment puis-je t'aider ? » au lieu de « Sors ».
Ces efforts ont porté leurs fruits,
les résultats scolaires continuent d'être à la hausse.
Je suis ravie de dire qu'à 10 ans,
D posait rarement problème.
Il était sûr de lui,
et cette attitude se propagea aux autres élèves.
L'ambiance à l'école s'améliorait,
elle devenait un cocon de sécurité et de joie pour les enfants,
mais aussi pour les adultes.
Peu importe ce qu'il se passait en dehors.
Désormais,
j'encadre un programme d'éducation alternatif destiné
aux étudiants qui ne sont pas à l'aise avec le système scolaire traditionnel.
Il y a peu, j'ai découvert leurs parcours.
Beaucoup ont 17 ou 18 ans,
consomment de la drogue,
sont incarcérés en centre de détention pour mineurs,
et se font renvoyer de l'école.
J'ai noté que beaucoup affichaient les mêmes comportements
que chez le jeune D.
Je ne peux m'empêcher de me demander :
si ces jeunes avaient appris plus tôt à gérer leurs émotions de manière saine
lorsqu'ils éprouvent des difficultés,
auraient-ils été capables de s'intégrer dans l'environnement scolaire ?
Je ne peux pas l'affirmer,
mais je pense que cela les aurait grandement aidés.
Il est temps de prendre le développement social et émotionnel de nos enfants
au sérieux.
Nous devons déterminer dès aujourd'hui les changements à apporter pour nos enfants.
Si nous leur apprenons à lire et à écrire,
mais qu'une fois diplômés, ils ne savent pas gérer leurs émotions,
de quoi aura l'air notre future société ?
Je le répète :
investir aujourd'hui ou subir plus tard.
Il est grand temps d'investir dans nos enfants.
Ils sont notre futur,
pas seulement des numéros qui réussissent ou non leurs examens.
Merci.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)